[Musica]
dopo si è allora innanzitutto stai calmo
primo secondo identificate che vidi quel
fare quello che vuoi
chiedo scusa io immaginavo un po diverso
più come ti pongo ma l'anziano la barba
lunga tipo griffi bravo tipo che i film
bravo ha il tempo di guardare i griffin
to voglio posso avere tante forme
diverse in base alle credenze della
gente ma beato te io non riesco mai
capiti in armi capelli al mattino
[Musica]
era una battuta come chiude il tuo primo
o un lavoro perché dica che da recensire
un film
e ti pareva per una porcheria senz'anima
uscita dalla valle degli scriventi è una
donna sana che cos'è
ho aspettato che arrivasse ai 300.000
iscritti prima di contattarti 300.000
non te l'aspettavi vero
anch'io mi chiedo come faccia la gente
ha seguiti da così tanto 20
ormai si è cambiato negli anni fosse più
il vecchio libro ci sono anche passati
sei anni e le persone cambiano
dovresti mostrare più grossi tubi di
capito ma si è venuto qui per insultarlo
per farmi vedere i film bambini loro
chelsea raul ma si dai non credo sia
così tragico comunque 300 mila
jesus christ vampire hunter film
armatoriale del 2001 diretto da lee
demarbre non voglio rovinarvi nulla
partiamo con la trama il film inizia con
una voce fuori campo che ricorda che
siamo tutti peccatori ma non voglio
finire all'inferno io giuro che non mi
sono mai masturbato credo del fumo fatti
i fatti tuoi
quando ad un certo punto arriva un
santone che assomiglia spaventosamente
dall'album onlive è normale che quello
che dovrebbe professare la religione
parli come se fosse posseduto da satana
e da qui inizia il vero film
[Musica]
con dei titoli di testa usciti fuori da
quello che gli anni settanta pensavano
fosse il futuro
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi è venuta una strana voglia di
cotonare i capelli di ascoltare i bee
gees ma spostiamoci in un parcheggio nel
mezzo della notte
[Musica]
non so cosa mi turbi di più che la
bambina sia lenta con una puntata di
sentieri o il fatto che una scena lesbo
fabi resca sia contenuta in un film con
gesù come protagonista ma mi tolgo ogni
dubbio dopo il primo vero dialogo del
film
sento odore di capolavoro lesbiche il
film contiene gesù vampiri e lesbiche è
praticamente un regalo di natale
anticipato e alla faccia tua twilight
non serve sbar luccicare come una disco
ball
basta avere degli occhiali da sole
prestare alla luce del giorno ok qui mi
hai preso la sprovvista un pre di con il
crestone ancora mi mancava
magari qualcuno di voi se la prenderà
per questo ma non prendetelo seriamente
forse vuole farti capire che chiunque
può abbracciare il signore a prescindere
dal suo aspetto fisico ma o forse solo
umorismo da quattro soldi probabilmente
fatto sta che il problema a lesmo
vampiri sta dando fuori controllo è solo
una persona può rimettere a posto la
situazione
[Musica]
non ebrei dove piena però di poeti e
proprio mentre stanno parlando arrivano
tre vampire dimmi che sta per fare
quello che immagino e quando pensi che
il film non potrebbe essere più
spettacolari di così ci ficcano dentro
le arti marziali
oddio più o meno arti marziali
le coreografie sono tremendamente
amatoriali ma apprezzo lo sforzo
purtroppo padre cresta il suo collega
muoiono e questo per jesús vuol dire
vendetta diamo il benvenuto a gesù 2.0
[Musica]
dopo una canzone in cui lancia miracoli
a caso si incontra con padre eustachio
che lo ospita nella sua chiesa
gli spiega che ci sono state delle
misteriose sparizioni nell'ultimo
periodo forse legate ai vampiri così si
va a fare shopping di palette mi sembra
giusta ma qualcuno non è d'accordo con
il ritorno del figlio di dio gli atei e
giù di mazzate
altro sono decine e decine sbucati fuori
dalla stessa auto compreso un esperto di
arti marziali sembra ovvio
no
ok questa scena la devo ripetere almeno
altre tre volte in loop non ce la faccio
è troppo bello tornato a casa trova una
donna armata ad aspettarlo ma non è una
vampira fa parte del gruppo apostolo
degli apostoli e mentre si fanno una
sauna ok gli racconta che devono
incontrare un uomo per sopperire al
problema vampirismo
ma prima devono cambiare vestiti embè ed
ecco un altro classico né degli anni 90
montaggio del camerino
[Musica]
e cala dopo aver visto questo o un
biglietto assicurato per l'inferno puoi
contarci ma bussare east ufficio no e
non a fare che se questo il dritto
dritto nel girone c melfi ci ho capito
ma non è che ogni cosa che faccio è
beccato al point salvezza
vabbè ma non è che sta succedendo niente
di catastrofico e sto film dopo lo
shopping partono all'inseguimento di una
delle vampire fino ad un laboratorio
dove o mio dio un dottore si lava la
faccia con la pelle strappata da una
ragazza che ha riunito walking the light
continuo ad inseguirla dentro ad un
centro di riabilitazione e lesbiche non
voglio che qualcuno si offenda ma è
esattamente il posto in cui vanno e
fanno una strage ma quanto urla gesù
stesso che deve poi strattonarla per
fare stare zitta
fatto sta che raggiungono i tuoi
succhiasangue e parte un altro scazzotta
mento dove vengono sconfitti maria se la
tizia si chiama maria viene morsicata è
gesù per dei sensi dopo una breve
interruzione da parte di rob zombie gesù
viene trovato in mezzo alla strada da un
travestito ex
[Musica]
i toscani non è sicuro se non mi
denunciano dopo questo video sono l'uomo
più fortunato del mondo
come se non bastasse arriva anche dio
per non abbassare il livello di demenza
del film dio appare sotto forma di una
ciotola di gelato alla marina prima di
urlare al capolavoro
guardate qui dio stesso gli assegna come
nuovo assistente e il santo un [ __ ]
dressler messicano
ho visto un toro e ora è il momento di
gridare tutti insieme capolavoro tu
passi tutta la tua vita a guardare film
di merda film di serie z e non
penseresti mai che si potrebbe arrivare
a certi livelli
ogni finché vedi di cibo questo è il
fondo oppure banco e se il capolavoro
del trash ma l'umanità riesce a stupirmi
sempre di più grazie
e sapete qual è la cosa bella è che non
avete ancora visto niente
subito dopo vanno in un locale zeppo di
bambini ed iniziava decimarli con una
mossa di ingegno che neanche macgyver il
nostro eroe beve un sorso di birra la
benedice e la spruzzo in faccia a tutti
se non è genio questo io mi sparano i
calcagni
[Musica]
il capo dei vampiri e rapisce la manager
di e il santo e dopo essersi preparato e
di aver parlato con sua madre
all'esponente c'è campagna arricchite in
presidente a ok la madonna è
rappresentata da una madonnina
speravo in qualcosa tipo un piatto di
riso cantonese che ne so
riparte per l'ennesima volta lo scontro
devo dire che questi scontri fatti così
amatoriali inizia a diventare
leggermente pesantucci da seguire perché
fanno cagare semplicemente persona
stavolta gesù viene rapito il licata ad
un'auto ma ronzan fortunatamente è il
salto riesce a liberarlo e continua la
lotta
[Musica]
tra crocifissi fatti di tergicristalli e
budella umane
no non è il nuovo the human senti pip e
grazie anche al suo dono dell'ubiquità
che gli permette di lottare contro due
persone diverse
il nostro eroe e viene pugnalati simo al
petto bene così
[Musica]
e poi succede questo gesù finisce in un
limbo che sembra l'opening di un
concerto degli slayer in cui non si
capisce una letta
ma dopo che si difende i vampiri sono
tutti morti
forse si sono redenti riesce anche a
guarire mary che si innamora di lui è il
tutto finisce con un piccolo discorso su
cosa è giusto e cosa è sbagliato condito
da una musica del tutto fuori luogo
quindi questo piccolo capolavoro finisce
qui devo dire che non mi sono mai
divertito così tanto a guardare un film
trash
infatti molte scene ve le ho dette
abbozzate perché voglio che voi andiate
a guardare magari l'argomento religioso
può essere fastidioso per qualcuno lo
capisco ma in realtà è talmente leggero
che non lo trovate offensivo quindi io
vi ringrazio ancora tantissimo per i 300
mila iscritti e ci vediamo ad un
prossimo video che il ghiaccio avuto il
film si può dire piaciuto attenta che la
risposta compatta la scelta burro scelto
tra la vita e la morte
il cinema è piaciuto o non ci è piaciuto
dopo tutti questi anni youtube
inizia ad avere dei dubbi 300.000
iscritti non solo uno scherzo è vero che
negli ultimi mesi non sono stato attivo
come sa venuto essere dopo tutto questo
tempo le idee iniziano a calare rischi
di far uscire i video tutti uguali
le alternative sono poche o hai le palle
di continuare cercando mille modi
diversi per andare avanti oppure molli
finché si è in tempo
sì forse e arrivata l'ora di mollare
forse e arrivata l'ora di gettare questa
maledetta spugna veramente mi fa
soltanto un enorme piacere aver scelto
questo film per chiudere in bellezza
quello che dovrebbe essere preso come
punto di riferimento di tutti i film
trash l'apice dei film di serie z
mettendoci dentro tutto quello che ti
viene in mente facendo soltanto perché
vuoi far divertire la gente
facendomi ridere dalla mattina alla sera
quindi si è il film mi è piaciuto
e se farmi piacere questo film significa
mandare a puntare sia lì di canale e
farmi finire all'inferno
fate pure
[Musica]
[Applauso]